i'm here at the very first crypto connect event
in miami sponsored by future perfect ventures
so today we have a really exciting interview
coming up but before we jump into it i do want
to let you know that this particular interview
is sponsored by exodus wallet so a huge thank you
to exodus wallet because without them we wouldn't
be able to bring you such great content so exodus
wallet is a next generation digital marketplace
and cryptocurrency wallet very easy to use very
easy to download it's available on mobile it's
available on desktop you can use it on android
you can use it on iphone whichever you prefer and
to be honest it's my number one pick when it comes
to cryptocurrency wallets joining me today is
the sec commissioner hester pierce to give us
the full landscape or the relationship between the
sec and cryptocurrencies hester great to have you
how are you it's so delightful to be here thanks
for having me and i have to start with my standard
disclaimer which is that my views represent
my own views not necessarily those of the sec
or my fellow commissioners well i appreciate
the disclaimer we appreciate it and uh we're
really excited to have you here there's a lot to
discuss so i'm going to jump straight into it and
i do want to start with the most recent piece of
news which was that van x spot etf was rejected so
can we we understand why that might have been and
also what do you look for when you go to approve
an etf so as with many regulatory things this is
a little bit complicated that was a staff decision
and um the commission that that's now been
pulled up for the commission to take a look at it
which means that i can't talk about that
particular one but what i can say is that in
the past what we've looked at is is the bitcoin
market the underlying bitcoin market is that
regulated in a way that looks familiar to us as a
securities regulator and so so far with there have
been a number of applications and on all of them
we've come out and we've said no we don't think so
over my dissent um i i will say that i've i've
written a couple dissents on this um and and
continue to be concerned that not making this
kind of product available to retail investors
is problematic um i think it's it's an option that
again depending on the facts and circumstances it
makes sense to make this option available
to people who want it of course there was
the futures etf which has been approved so
can you explain to me what the difference is
between the spot etf and the futures etf and
why it's harder to get that sport etf through
i know many people including myself were a
lot more excited for the sport ethio so the
the point i made about us wanting to have that
market be regulated in the way our markets are
regulated is is how we got to where we are
with a futures based product getting approved
the futures markets are regulated by the commodity
futures trading commission and that's our sister
regulator and we're very comfortable with those
markets and so something built on top of that
looks really familiar to us and and we can get
comfortable with that and there's a difference
between an exchange traded product which is
a broad category in an exchange traded fund
the futures based product that got approved as
an etf which means that it's subject to this
special regulatory regime that's intended to
protect retail investors and so our new chair
uh chair gary gensler made it clear that people
should come in with id with with applications for
futures-based exchange-traded funds and so indeed
people came in and those were approved so it's
it's a step forward but it's not the spot product
that a lot of people were interested in seeing
that said there's been quite a bit of interest
investor interest in these early futures based
products and given the amount of interest that we
are also seeing in that sport etf how do you have
a timeline that you can share with us is that
possible at all you know i i've been asked that
question i've been at the sec four years and i've
been asked that question since virtually the first
day i started at the sec and my my predictions i
tend not to make predictions i say i don't know
but i tell people that sec time is definitely
not like crypto time it can take a very long
time and so i think again there's there's no
one should should be looking um and expecting
something to happen until we get over this
rationale that we've been using which is i
would argue a different rationale for for the one
we've applied to similar products based on other
types of things i'd like to understand from
your perspective what the sec sentiment is
towards cryptocurrencies because we have seen a
lot of um hostility perhaps from the us government
the lack of um clarity in the infrastructure bill
i know upset the crypto community quite a lot
um so what is the sec's general sentiment towards
cryptos well so i started out by saying that my
views represent my own and so the commission is
made up of five different commissioners one of
whom is the chairman gary gensler and we all have
different perspectives on all kinds of things and
so this is no no different right there there are
a whole slew of different perspectives and um
then there's the staff as well with about 4
500 people and so there are a lot of different
experiences and sets of expertise that people
bring when they look at something like crypto
so there's no one view but that said chair
gensler is someone who spent several years at mit
teaching about financial technology
about crypto specifically and so he
brings an understanding of the potential
for the space he also is someone who really
likes a nice regulatory structure and so i
think that there are people who want to see
innovation happen but they want it to happen in
a very regulated frame and and that's what we're
seeing some of and then there there are people
like me who who say you know we need to develop
a regulatory framework that makes sense and that
that really um allows innovation to happen and
and i'm i'm more worried about the objective
that we're meeting the objectives of financial
regulation which without saying it has to
look exactly like the regulatory framework
that we have on the the non-crypto side so there's
a diversity of views and we'll see where that ends
up shaking out but i think the positive is that
more people in washington are spending more time
thinking about crypto and you know certainly
learning more about it and that's that's going
to be positive i think at the end of the day
for for regulation so it's all about that fine
line between stifling innovation and of course
protecting the investor there is concern that
it could potentially stifle innovation within the
us and america really should be at the forefront
of this inevitable industry so what is the sec
doing to make sure that regulation doesn't make
america essentially fall behind the rest of the
world well and i think it's important to remember
the sec is one of many regulators in the united
states that has a potential interest in crypto so
we we have a piece to play in making this a very
innovation-friendly place but it's not only our
job and our mission is to protect investors to
facilitate capital formation and to maintain
foster efficient and orderly markets so that's
what we're thinking about when we go about our job
i do agree with you that the us should be the
place that people want to come to innovate it
should be the place people want to come to
invest and build their companies um but we
you know we have a a very strong regulatory
structure here and so it's going to take some time
to figure out how to build that or or
amend that structure so that it works
well not only with the technology of today
that we're seeing but that it's it it will last
and so it's it's not an easy project we definitely
need to get a lot of people working on it and
not just people at the sec but people who
are investing in this space people who are
going to be regulated by whatever regulations we
draft um and it's it's it's not an easy project
it's not an easy project and for that reason i
do just want to bring up xrp i know of course
you can't speak about it directly but it might
be classed as a security so it would be helpful
for the audience to understand how are you
looking at something and how are you classing
whether classing whether it's a security we'll
start that how would you decide whether something
is a security and certainly don't want to speak
specifically to any particular crypto asset but
but what i'll say is that our definition in
the us of security is a broad one there are
some other countries that have very precise
definitions but ours is intentionally broad
and the idea is we don't want to capture
just things that you know stock or bonds
that you would know our securities but we want to
capture things that someone might call something
different but is nevertheless the same idea and
so the in the crypto world the one that's gotten
the the piece of the definition that's gotten
a lot of attention is investment contract and
an investment contract was defined by something
called the howie test which comes from a supreme
court case about orange groves which now
a lot of people in the crypto world know
and the idea is if you give me money and i tell
you i'm going to build something all you need
to do is give me your money you're going to get
an investment return on your money just sit back
i'll do the work and then that looks a lot
like a security a securities offering right
and so and so we're gonna treat that as a
securities offering we're gonna regulate that
and so that's kind of how we look at it
through that lens now there are other pieces of
the definition of security like what's a note
that may come up in the crypto context as well
but we're generally trying to capture anything
that looks like one of the more traditional
types of securities and you said that the sec um
takes things slowly we were speaking earlier and
you spoke about you know you can't walk before
you can run but there are other cryptocurrencies
um that people are concerned could be classed
as a security and i know you can't speak to any
specifically but from the sec standpoint
do you think that there could be more and
other cryptocurrencies that have the same
future as xrp's going through right now well
again i don't want to talk about any specific
crypto asset but i i think it's telling that
our chair our chair chair gensler has said that
he sees most digital assets as being securities
and that may be a different view than i personally
take but i think there's been a very expansive
reading of the definition of security not
only in the context of crypto assets to be
to be fair it's been in other areas as
well we've taken a pretty expansive view
and so you know that's that's kind of the world
we're living in so the question that i say is okay
i might disagree with my colleagues on how broad
that definition should be but if we're going to
use that broad definition we need to think about
what does that mean what is that if if you put the
label security on something a whole set of rules
has to follow from a whole set of requirements
follows from that right and so how are we going
to deal with those requirements in the digital
asset space where those requirements could prevent
people from doing things they might otherwise do
so there are a lot of hard questions we
have to answer if we're going to define
a lot of crypto assets as securities as as some
want to do i want to move on to talk about the
sec's role in terms of protecting the individual
investor so i want to look at the safe harbor rule
so does the sec actually have plans to allow the
smaller um investor that isn't an accredited an
accredited investor the opportunity to participate
in lucrative opportunities particularly the types
of opportunities that you do tend to see in
crypto well so we have rules in the us that are
a little bit counter to our traditional
approach in the united states which is that
people should be able to spend their money
the way they want you know they they should
bear the risk and bear the responsibility
but also bear the the chance to make a
return right that that should be their choice
but we have these rules that say no we have
private markets and those private markets are
mostly going to be for people who are wealthy
or have a high income and for other people they
need to invest in the pro in the public markets
there's some exceptions to that but mostly
that's how it works and so a lot of people
push back and say wait a minute you have to have
a lot of money to participate in this whole set
of investment opportunities and i think that's a
little bit uncomfortable too i would rather have
a situation where we said no you can participate
over here but you're not going to get the same
protections in the private markets that you'll get
in the public markets but we've been very slow to
adjust that now we actually did recently make a
major it's a minor step but in a way it's a major
change in the way we're thinking to say
you know what maybe there's some people
who aren't wealthy who don't have high incomes
who should nevertheless qualify as accredited
so we open the door to the idea that if you have
the right kind of educational certification maybe
then you should be qualified you should be able to
qualify as an accredited investor or maybe someone
will come up with a test and maybe if you pass
that test you should be able to be an accredited
investor so i'm hopeful that maybe we'll move
a little bit off this wealth and income test
but um it it still it does make a lot of people
very unhappy that we have those rules in place
because there's a lot of unemployment
right now we're seeing high inflation
and a lot of people do look to cryptocurrencies as
sort of the last resort the only opportunity right
now to really build long lasting generational
wealth and they do feel ostracized um you know
if they are at the bottom of the food chain if
you want to put it like that so to what extent
is it really the sec's role to police that to take
away their free choice to decide how much risk
they wish to take as an individual well i think
you're raising an important question right from
my perspective the sec's role is a disclosure role
right it's it's to help people get the information
they need to make decisions for themselves right
and they know the circumstances of their lives
they know what their job opportunities are they
know um what the potential expenses coming down
the pike are we don't know those things they know
their own risk tolerance we don't know that so
our job though is to make sure that someone when
there's an information asymmetry which means that
the person selling you the securities knows
a lot more about what her plans are than
the person buying the securities we want to
even out that and say you know what person
selling securities you better give certain
information to the person buying so there's a
role there to be played but there's also a role
to be played in investor education which means
that we're helping people realize you can ask
questions yourself when you're buying something
don't just put your money down and walk away and
assume that everything will be fine ask questions
if you see something that looks suspicious go
invest your money somewhere else there are lots
of opportunities out there and so i think if we
if we try to make the sec not a merit regulator
but keep it in its role as a disclosure regulator
we really do a better job of protecting people
because then we can tell them look ultimately it's
your choice and you've got to do your own homework
here are some material we can provide
educational materials to help them do that
provide them some lists of red flags think
they should things they should look out for
but ultimately the decision has to
be on the investor herself not on
on the sec sounds like a really healthy balance
one that i definitely support but how likely is it
to see an sec that looks like that well the sec
is not supposed to be a merit regulator and so
um we really don't have the authority to do that
i think we sometimes wander into merit regulation
territory where we're you know trying to put
ourselves in the shoes of the investor and say
you shouldn't invest in this or you should invest
in that and it's natural because we see a lot of
really bad frauds and there is a lot of fraud
in the financial space and the security space
and people do need to be careful they can
really get hurt and so it's understandable
that you know regulators get concerned but i think
it's important that we maintain that balance and
that when we get out of balance the people who
we serve say wait a minute you're supposed to
stick to your role which is not to be a merit
regulator not to tell us what to invest in but
just to help us get the information we need and
i'd love to understand and learn about really
your experience with cryptocurrency so how did you
first hear about it do you own any um give us the
landscape sure well i first heard about it from
colleagues in my in my last job some of whom were
really interested in in the crypto world and were
doing a lot of research on it and so um i learned
a lot from them about it and then when i got to
the sec there were a lot of crypto issues kind
of percolating up to the to the sec and so those
were issues that i was naturally interested in
because i i think it's always interesting to see
where innovation is happening and then how that
innovation gets handled by regulators not always
well um i do not own any crypto i think given the
role that i play it would be inappropriate
for me to do so so i don't have any crypto
it's a really interesting um response because i
often hear that from journalists as well um you
know it would be a conflict of interest um but
just finally i'd also love to talk about cbdc's
with you central bank digital currencies how does
that come into play in terms of regulation what
can we expect is the sec for against it what's
the overview well so it is a little bit outside
the sec's purview and i will say that i not only
don't speak for the sec i don't speak for the
for the fed and the the federal reserve
is looking into they've made public that
they're looking into a potential should we
have a cbdc if so what should it look like
what i will say is that we have a lot of private
stable coins now um and you know there's been
a lot of growth in that space and there's
it's something i think to have competition
and to have not a government not a government
digital currency but private digital currency
i think is is valuable from a financial privacy
perspective um and so whereas other countries may
decide that they want a cbdc we might be able
to and i think one of the one of the federal
reserve officials has spoken about this this
the the private stable coins might fulfill the
same role here in the united states and so that's
something that um we should we should welcome that
innovation um and and remember that as we're
thinking about how to regulate stable coins
remember that they can serve a valuable role in
our economy so just finally how do you expect from
one year to five years from now roughly i know
it's quite a long time the regulatory framework to
look like um towards cryptocurrencies in the usa
you know it's so hard to look down the road even
a year i think this is going to be an important
year for crypto regulation because there's been a
lot of attention on it five years down the road
it's hard to say i mean congress may at some
point get involved in this space and certainly
already there are a lot of people in congress
who have gotten involved they've dropped uh bills
about you know with different potential approaches
to regulating crypto um but if there were actually
something that passed congress that would be
monumental and directing how that regulation
would work i think what you're seeing right now
is a lot of regulators are planting their flags
by for example bringing enforcement actions you
hear a lot of statements coming from different
regulators saying we should have a piece of this
regulatory space but others say no no it should
be ours and so there's a lot of jockeying for
position now which i think we're gonna see that
continue in the in the coming years um and and
i think those enforcement efforts will play a
role in you know allocating the regulatory pie
but there there are a lot of unknowns
and that's why i really encourage people
who are in this space who are interested in
how this space is regulated come talk to me
come talk to my colleagues it is better for all
of us if we can build a regulatory structure that
makes sense that achieves the objectives that we
have the legitimate objectives right of protecting
investors having these markets function
um in a way that's that's orderly and that
doesn't end up having effects outside of the
crypto markets so let's have this conversation
together and let's do this in a wise way it
really should not be viewed as the government
is just going to set the regulations and
that's how it's going to be it has to be
an exercise that involves all of us that's what
regulation is supposed to be about and so please
keep that conversation happening i'd love to hear
from all of you this has been fantastic to have
this conversation and i hope that we'll be able to
continue having these conversations yeah i want to
thank you so much it's been such a pleasure hester
i think these conversations are so important i
know the community are concerned um about how the
future is going to look so hearing it straight
from yourself um is absolutely brilliant so thank
you so much for coming to talk to us today it's
been my pleasure thank you thank you everyone for
watching and thank you to exodus waller of course
for sponsoring this and making this happen if you
haven't already then hit the subscribe button hit
the like button and so you never miss an amazing
interview on my channel thanks for watching
you